chelsey Jane's here on the program how
are you doing Chelsea good how are you I
am doing fine let's let's start with the
the obvious involving Bryce Harper what
happened yesterday best you can tell no
I think that they felt like they had to
see what they could get for him you know
I think they felt like they'd be
irresponsible about to see if they could
get blown away with an offer and they
didn't and you know I don't think they
were ever determined to sell Bryce but
like mike rizzo their GM said you know
it'd be pretty stupid of us not if we
could get something and and from all I
heard they were asking for some pretty
ridiculous packages from people they
didn't get him and they said we're just
gonna see what happens the rest away
with what we've got and let Bryce play
it out is there any possibility that
there was something that was close
enough to tantalize mike rizzo and
ownership just put the kibosh on it
Chelsea that's what we're still kind of
trying to piece together I don't get the
sense that it got that close but it
might us but they were definitely
talking lis it's the night on Monday
night and then at some point today
morning Rizzo says no no we're not going
to do this so maybe there was a moment
in there where it got close they they
kind of said we can't pull this off but
you know the sense I get is the office
we're never gonna be quite enough and
you know so they said they called crisis
to take your saying well I mean you have
to figure the offers would never get
close enough in the fact that you know
you've got a guy represented by Scott
Boras and usually those clients do like
to test the free agent market so you're
only renting him and if you're only
renting him then you know somebody like
Rizzo can't turn around and trade a
generational talent like Harper and say
we only could get this because he's a
rental I don't think Nationals fans who
cheered at the Home Run Derby would be
able to swallow that so I guess the
ultimate question is is why was there a
listening tour at all Chelsea
you know I I think you had to you know I
mean I don't have a problem with I'm
sort of looking around and being at
someone will bite because like you think
he is a general talent and if you're say
you're the Astros and you could tell
your plants off Bryce Harper and you're
gonna go for it again or or you know it
seems sort of on the cusp like the A's
or somebody like that and you just go
for it for a few months I mean that that
sounds a pretty strong message as well
for teams that might be sort of not your
usual contenders so I think there was
reason to believe they might get
something and also he makes a lot of
money and if if there was a point I
think they were really considering maybe
offloading a lot of payroll and just
found that they weren't getting the
value they wanted but had there been a
wholesale sell-off which I think was you
know was something they were thinking
about you could offload the rest of the
21 million dollar salary and get
something back - I think that's very
appealing because they're over the
luxury tax they hate that so Chelsea
jeans in the Washington Post her then I
guess let me just put the the fartist
point on the question as I can then is
there something wrong with Bryce Harper
and DC that that they just decide that
even if they do get bowled over let's
trade them because again the
generational town I don't think that the
angels are gonna be on a listening tour
for Mike Trout anytime soon and yet they
were for Bryce Harper and DC is there
something something underneath the
surface that is just inherently wrong
and not a match there Chelsea well I
mean I think it'd be silly that you know
my trout's not afraid to have food and
they're not you know really in it I
think this team had an argument to make
that they should sell and get something
for all their pending free agents so you
know I don't think if no obviously this
wasn't the topic of discussion last year
it it's just sort of you know they're
almost out of it do we have to go
scramble to get something that being
said I do think there's sort of a not
attention but Bryce's a polarizing guy
you know I think this organization has
really cleared the way for him to feel
comfortable and in so doing you can
created some double standards you know
we saw Trey Turner get bench for not
running something out we thought Bryce
get potentially talked to if that and
you know that's just one example that
you know people notice people around the
clubhouse notice and I think this you
know they got the arbitration deal down
like right two years in advance they
wanna you know have anything to clinch
is happening this year they just wanted
him to get the free agency itself a good
chance of getting along when they're
negotiating so you know I think he's
somebody they really have to plan around
and they maneuver around and they do a
lot for and so it there is a tension
there but it's not you know that no mike
rizzo love bryce harper you said that he
defends it to the desk you know Dave
Dave Martinez and Harper have a great
relationship but he's still Bryce Harper
he's the guy that that everybody has an
opinion on it and there's wait it comes
with that there's sort of responsibility
on the part of an organization and and
it's I think it where's some time
Chelsea James of the Washington Post
here on the Rich Eisen show okay let's
get in what happened with Sean Kelly
Chelsea you know I don't think he wanted
to be pitching in the 25 to one game
he's a veteran he's been around he's
been pitching well and when he went out
there he seems to sort of carry that
frustration with him and what things
didn't go well he he threw his glove
that's part of it but then he also
glared in the dugout is to say why am I
in the same and you know on the same day
they basically traded another reliever
because they thought he was you know
calling into question the clubhouse
culture in Brandon Kinsler you know they
weren't a lot Sean Kelly show up his
manager like that yeah I think it's a
symptomatic of what's been happening
here that said results behind his new
rookie manager he's saying doubling down
he's saying look this is our guy you're
either with us or against us and those
are sheer veteran guys but had their own
thoughts and obviously what a voice or
showed them and the gloves grow was just
it sort of ruin what was otherwise a
really kind of good day for them and a
season where there have been a lot of
good days and it just seemed selfish for
a guy to come into a 25 to one game and
make it about him and giving up a home
run and his stats and everything but
that he sort of applied there so then
what is wrong with the clubhouse cuz I
you know obviously you know I read your
reports I read your stories and you know
you hear about Scherzer holding a
players only meeting you hear about
Scherzer in Strasburg not being on the
same page you hear about this you hear
about that
you know what is going on there so it's
interesting you know Adam Eaton has said
I've been into this functional
clubhouses and this ain't it and yeah he
was there when Chris Sale cut up jerseys
in Chicago you see my and it's not that
you know but I think what it is is you
took a team that had won 95 games two
years in a row with Dusty Baker and you
fired him and you brought in a guy who's
never done this before and said listen
to this guy and then things didn't go
well
you know it was sort of inevitable that
a veteran team was gonna start asking
questions and I think they did I think
we saw believers you know more than just
Kelly and Kinsler say I don't I don't
know that I like what he's doing you
know he's not experienced we can't trust
him
I don't give a sense from a lot of other
people in there that they worry about
about what he's doing you know Davy is
universally liked and pretty much
everyone starts their conversation with
he's a great guy you know so at least
that's their but I think it's just kind
of a perfect storm of a veteran
Clubhouse with a new guy and an
expectation that you win that you know
anything less than 95 one season at this
appointment so I think there were guys
asking questions um I think there was
sort of a collective underachievement
there's a lot of guys in contract years
sort of focused inward instead of on the
team and I think it's all kind of
confined to put a lot of pressure on
these guys and and losing doesn't help
it I we wouldn't be talking about this
they were ten games over but they're not
for a myriad of reasons that definitely
don't all have to do with their
clubhouse culture so I guess the last
one Chelsea for somebody who's been
around Bryce Harper for as long as you
have and nationally you know we see him
he wants to make baseball fun again we
see the video you know that I guess his
brother put out of him using two hair
dryers to hair blow his hair
we saw what he did at the home run derby
he is definitely one of the most
recognizable names faces who is he
though who is Bryce Harper best you can
tell
it's tough to tell I mean I've been
around in for years and I've tried to
figure that out I think I think the part
that people don't see is that he's a guy
who really loved his family isn't
obsessed with baseball you know you know
doesn't if he doesn't love the spotlight
as much as seems like he does or maybe
as he did early in his career and I
think to the weight of everything that
you know his prominence has read on to
him has seemed to weigh on it the last
couple years and he's not that make
baseball phone again guy anymore you
know he's he's quiet
he doesn't talk a lot in the clubhouse
you you know he wants to go home after
games and get out of there he's not
trying to call it much of yourself so
it's really interesting but you know for
me right now Bryce Harper's a guy who's
feeling pressure and sort of a normal
human who has a lot of people looking at
him a lot of people analyzing him and as
a result has sort of just kind of tried
to sink into the background as much as
he possibly can but nobody left them all
right Chelsea thanks for the time we
appreciate it let's check it check back
in with you as things begin to heat up
one way or another for the Nationals you
got to enjoy your work that's Chelsea
Jaynes of the Washington Post Chelsea
underscore James the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience